listen so the premier New York Premiere
was last night and I got to attend
obviously you guys were as well
um what is it like
watching the movie with an audience like
that because they were so emotionally
invested in the film crazy as things
were happening like the people around me
were freaking out and screaming and it
was it was pretty intense for uh like uh
yeah that was super expressive yeah that
was lovely to do a film like that and to
have an audience engaging with you like
that and like feeling it like that
expressing it I mean it was great it
felt it felt like life theater
especially coming from France you know
people are not so expressive in the
cinemas and last night was incredible
for me it was incredible the reactions
were like I was thinking whoa what an
experience to watch this movie with the
audience it was really unique for me I
never forget that yeah you know it's
beautiful just to go from laughs to like
reactions of action and like that
emotion up in big action scenes like the
way they expressed them like
everybody like yeah no it was like your
whole Cinema was like I were relief
I was gonna say it you know that people
care about the characters when they had
such a strong reaction so Sam obviously
did a great job because people were so
invested in thing you know what I mean
yeah yeah you know that was a great
fight I would say to manage to do an
action movie that people would get
involved emotionally because now these
days action movies are like Tick Tock
you do not engage with the characters
you don't care about them if they die
you don't feel anything you don't feel
anything it doesn't touch you but Sam
wanted it some worked hard for that and
I really give him this credit that he
did it yeah 100 there is some sequences
in the film that I'm like I don't know
how Sam did this you know they were so
intense and you know obviously stitching
together takes and whatnot but for both
of you which shotter sequence in the
movie was like how the f are we gonna do
this how oh yeah like how complicated is
it gonna be like you know like yeah like
the difficulty like which shotter scene
was the one that you know what I mean it
was just crazy difficult
most difficult uh wow that's a good
question um well to be honest like
some State I remember that day where
we're driving in the forest you know the
car chase with the motorcycles and I
remember because we we didn't drive
right
so there was a rally driver professional
guy like very very talented guy and I
remember he was writing very fast I
don't know in miles per hour you guys
thought I talks in kilometers but he was
like running fast like very fast between
trees and like the trees were really
narrow and I came like I can tell you
like even if you're the I thought you
almost had an accident
like I I remember and I said how are
they gonna film this ditch how are they
going to film this that the motorcycles
everywhere between Pines and the cars
are running so fast and they're like
explosion everything
yeah the guys are looking driving from
like back there with all the mud and all
the motorcycles and true motorcycles and
and other cars and Sam and Tyler and I
was like wow how they gonna film this
without no accident like I mean how it
could happen I mean so complicated the
shot and you had you had it was a long
Stitch with two three explosion two
three setups and then some tied to a car
with nothing as if like he's in that
traction park with nothing with a camera
like this and that car was going in the
middle of it crazy I was like this guy
is dedicating his life to cinema it's
like and he's a director and he was
carrying the camera he was unbelievable
yeah he was he was really like involved
for me also this was the aspect also for
me on the personal level it was my fight
it was really I was I was very worried
about it I think this was a global thing
and then you had the more personal I
think that you would say like
yeah we all had a fight to prepare for a
big one that's what I actually wanted to
follow up on when because I think people
don't realize how much training and
preparation goes to making a movie like
this so before you stepped on set how
many months or weeks I don't know what
it was where you're working all the time
to learn the the dance move of this
fight sequence or fight sequences two
months we went there before the shooting
it was the basic of our training that it
was like eight nine hours a day it was
unbelievable and then and during the
shooting well not eight nine hours but
you have you had to keep training
regularly but then you learned the
choreography basically you they will
teach you the choreography which that
also takes uh time so you're very
worried all the time about your fight
especially him I think he had to fight
with a real fighter and that was a
challenge because it's hard for a real
Fighters not to go for a punch so yeah
Megan Anderson was really yes strong if
you wanted to so I was like slow now you
know don't you know she comes from MMA
so she was like okay that I don't know
if I can hold it I'm like well you're
gonna have to
don't punch me please yeah no no it was
a great experience you know to to to be
there and to man to train first of all
you learned the whole fighting in films
and then the choreography and then
everything but we all had like big
fights to prepare for and if it's for
one one minute 30 seconds 45 second
fight in the film it's like weeks and
weeks of preparation for that yeah I I
just want to give credit because I could
not do any of it so uh you know you guys
made it look uh real and you know I'm
sure you could I'm sure you could this
body does not no no it's a big no
there's a lot of will we can do anything
nope
I definitely want to do a individual
question for you and this is going to
run obviously after the movie is out but
the movie ends in such a way with Idris
setting up what could be you know
something interesting I know this movie
is going to be a huge hit have you asked
Sam what does that mean when he says
this weird you know basically if you
asked him what goes on after or he's
sort of just like whatever happens
happens you mean for the third one I
think they're already cooking some stuff
for the third one nobody really talks
about it but it's actually happening
um I think it's funny that you would you
love these characters so much and you
want to know so much about them that you
would love to continue following them so
I guess there will be some stories and I
think there's a lot to explore more
because I think there are quite
mysterious character especially my
character there's so much you don't know
about her where she's from also they
don't have a sexualized relation
together but they're ready to die for
another so it's a very unique character
that we really we haven't had a warrior
Female warrior that is not a love
interest of someone and not in love with
someone so it's quite interesting their
chemistry but they they deeply they have
a deep bond together so I think there's
a lot to explore let's see what are they
cooking sure this is probably my last
question for the two of you uh what do
you think an extraction fan would be
surprised to learn about the actual
making of an extraction movie of I think
maybe the tricks of the Warner how they
the stitches they would be like where
are this the stitches how did they do
the stitches what you're saying it's not
all really done in 21 minutes oh no I
don't think so I mean I remember this
one shot that we were going in the car
and the camera they were coming out of
this ditch put the camera on the cable
the cable will take the camera up on the
bridge while everything was happening I
was like how this thing is going to work
how and then bringing down again putting
it on the camera it's like I think that
is the most interesting thing about the
tricks of the winner how where are these
stitches that would be interesting I'll
just leave it there I'll just say Hey
listen I really want to say congrats
thanks I know this is going to be a huge
hit and uh good luck